today's guest is the first mexican
born fighter to win a ufc championship
um he's a warrior
and and i'm inspired anytime i get to
sit down with any of these
uh any of these
these uh fighters i just feel inspired
um
i feel inspired as i'm sure a lot of you
guys do
uh
today's guest is out of the flyweight
division he's the pride of tijuana
mexico
and uh and i'm very grateful for his
time he is beloved
and uh and i'm gonna get to know him a
little bit better mr brandon moreno
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and i will find a song
[Applause]
yeah i think i would like to maybe be
i would probably like to be mexican i
think
what yeah
do it it's the best man do it
is it hard
well
to be mexican
depends on that
you know because i mean we can talk
about it in i don't know
about this but my my father's my parents
they were like
very poor yeah poor
but they start to work hard man and i
had a nice life
so i don't have like any necessities in
my life my parents was another whole
different history man it was different
huh yeah
and so to me was like oh i don't have
any necessities so everything was easy
oh for you it was easy but for them it
was different yeah
and that life is for uh the most the
the most part of the people that in
mexico is a dear world countryman it's
hard
yes tough huh yeah i wish i think
dude no joke when i get up in the
morning sometimes i freaking clap for
mexican people because
uh i think that they if it weren't for
mexican people america would be
nobody would be doing any i feel like
mexican people keep this country going
man i mean i have one year living here
man and i can see a lot of mexican
people like working like yeah hardman
hard-working like man these guys
all these guys are doing
their job right just to and it's
everywhere all across the country it's
like that man mexican i think if if it
weren't for mexican people i don't know
where
i don't know what america would be you
know
yeah you guys are like they're real like
the uh
rabitos you know
what is that oh i don't know
i don't know what is that it's like uh
you know the animal with the ears at
easter
oh rabbits rabbits all right
rabbits yeah you guys are the rabbits
man
um
anyway
uh thank you thanks for being here
oh we started already
okay
we started man but yeah i think when i
die i would like to come back and be
mexican next time because if scenes were
also a lot of romance and
is more romantic
yeah i mean
yeah we were talking about this before
right yeah i mean i feel like
the latin culture is like
more
with more happiness and everything yeah
that's awesome other cultures
they have his
uh their own fun right in life i don't
know a lot the latin culture has a lot
of traditions a lot of amazing food
this mix of cultures yeah i mean i mean
i i'm so happy and i'm so proud to be
mexican and and uh and be a latino so
yeah
dang dude
i wish next time i'm going to be 100
latino where did you say your father my
father's from nicaragua okay but uh but
he didn't really he just he talked
spanish with his friends but he never
taught me you know but i did really yeah
i i don't understand why i mean for
example i have my nephews my am i so
sorry my my cousins
yeah
um they speak bold language because in
in in their house was like
outside the school you can speak english
all the time but in the house you need
to speak spanish if not i don't
understand nothing oh really i'm i'm
trying to do the same with my daughter
man because again we have one year
living here in vegas
and
my my daughter she's she's uh eight
years oh nice congratulations
she went to school last year obviously
this the the pandemic was crazy and
everything but she started to go to the
school and i can see the more confidence
when she tried to speak english really
yeah and i thought i talked with her
before like hey
in the moment when and i can see you can
speak good english
you need to stop the english in the
house never i don't want to hear any
english word here because
espanola just spanish in the house man
it's more opportunities you know it's
your language it's your culture i mean
cheap cheap she born in in in
hemet in in california uh-huh yeah yeah
livestream
but seven years living living in in
tijuana
she's just mexican oh she's mexican man
yeah yeah dude but we're glad to have
her over here even for a year man um
do you
now that you like really have become
like
you've really become such a star you
know in a lot of ways a lot of people
people love you i was at a um
i was at uh
i was talking with someone about you
about the fight and they'd just gone to
your last fight which was in uh it was
in california right it was in anaheim
yeah and they said when you came out it
was the loudest they'd ever
s that they'd heard since conor mcgregor
man that's awesome i mean that's cool i
feel like you're like the mexican corner
yeah
thank you man
so
i feel like the people can connect uh
uh yeah why are we history oh with your
history you know yeah i mean with you
with my
my with my uh
the way i am with the people
and i don't know i always say the same
but for example the history of having
this guy
undefeated an amazing like a
wrestling god and everything right that
an amazing and perfect record
but i mean my history is more like
the history of the people yeah when
you fall
and you come back and you come back yeah
and that's like the people can identify
more that history on oh by himself than
other ones like hey i mean it's the same
i
won every time yeah as opposed to i've
lost and won and lost them one yeah and
and obviously i mean i'm just trying to
be happy and enjoy my job
and you know be very kind with the
people
um
and that's it then it's it's crazy how i
can connect with the people because i
don't need to
to say stupid things in the social media
or the trash talk or something like that
yeah i love it because i hate that like
to me it's very boring when
when some guy tried to trash out to do
the trash talking social media
on the in a press conference like me i
saw that before man like right nothing
new it's not you and it doesn't well i
guess it doesn't fit you some guys it
fits some guys can trash talk and it it
just fits their character
but i don't know if it probably wouldn't
fit your character you don't think yeah
i mean i said and i say this like even
if you
watch me mad in some place in a press
conference with some with somebody it's
because i'm really mad with the guys
right right
yeah you're not faking it um
do you go is it is it
because tijuana is a third world country
is it or mexico is a third world country
is it scary to go back to tijuana do you
get scared since you're more popular now
is it do you have any more fear is that
is that it's a good question man
and nothing against the mexican people
just no no no no i mean i'm very open
with when we talk about tijuana because
i know the good and the bad things man
yeah i love i love tijuana i love the
city i love my uh mexico the country we
have an amazing things the culture the
tradition the food my goodness the food
man the ladies bro the ladies the people
whatever you want
i love them um but at the same time i
understand about things you know the
narco traffic the violence uh is a
dangerous place too i understand that uh
but
i'm when i go to to to mexico i'm not
really a scare man because
i live there all my life right like 20
27 years i've been there like
getting an amazing time there training
uh meeting people and everything
sometimes i think
about maybe my family
you never you never know right that is
more scared for me
to me like you know because right now
right now i'm living in vegas but
um my parents live in tijuana and my
brothers lives in tijuana you know my
nature and they have kidnapping people
take people there sometimes so for
example
when uh some
channel uh asked me for an interview for
my father saying like i don't i don't
like to
er that get involved in all of this
because oh put them in this exactly it
could be dangerous yeah maybe you never
you never know me so i prefer to put
everything
uh out of the conversation and just be
me if you want to an interview and get
an interview for me i can do it man but
yeah
even with that i mean they had a few
interviews yeah yeah
um do they uh
do you
did you ever get approached by like any
drug people or anything after you've
become like a real success does does the
cartel like comment for you to like get
you to be their guy or anything oh man i
mean no thanks god yeah because people
like arnold julius are chavez yeah he
he he got approached by them he talked
about histories like
man so the narco trafficking come they
came with me you know because they love
boxing too oh and they start to come
with me and hey a congress jumps and
that's dangerous and actually that's why
julie julius starts traveling start to
involve with the drugs and everything
and start to have problems with that
but you don't see that for me not right
now and i'm so happy about you i'm glad
you know yeah and at the same time i'm
i mean
i think i'm very smart in that area i
don't smoke nothing i don't eat nothing
bad like you know i don't drink alcohol
or smoke cigars and everything in my
life so really i feel like very i very
smart in the in that area i had a really
nice people around me in all my life to
teach me a really good
things about all of the success and you
know a lot of good role models are a lot
of good role models definitely so yeah i
mean i i feel like
i can i can do it you can handle it i
can it's not going to happen to you
probably that that situation i mean you
never know i never i i don't like a
kingpin yeah maybe yeah
i don't get a tuxedo
yeah i don't think so
you could you could be like uh kind of
like a james bond uh but of drugs you
know
[Laughter]
no i i don't i like to to to
to wear nice yeah dress or wear how you
say
let me think i would say put on
you put on something nice dress
i mean i like it but when i even when i
dress i wear like suits or something
like so i i like to
wear something like very like very
relaxed like very normal just to do
looks elegant and that's it
do you uh did you guys do something for
valentine's day y'all go out do you
celebrate valentine's day
sometimes you know i i i
i have
almost 11 years with my wife wow yeah
she she was with me since when i had
like nothing man that's cool um where
did you meet her uh in tijuana yeah she
she born in in texas in texas okay so
she's um she was born american person
yeah yeah but she lives all uh her life
in in
no guella
olympus is the border
really so she's not she's mexican yeah
but she she went to tijuana with her um
sister
so i meet i meet her there she went to
the gym actually oh really you met her
at the gym yeah did you go talk to her
she can talk to you
both both
i think so i don't remember no but both
and then when she started to talk with
me i started i'm just trying to get fun
with everybody so i start to make jokes
with with her and then we start to talk
more and more and
and you took her out
yeah then you asked her out yeah and you
know and talk more and more and more and
now we have three dollars
a lot of talking yeah exactly
um but yeah i mean
i forget what
i was talking oh it's okay i was oh i
was asking about that valentine yeah but
yeah so sometimes just
for example
this last valentine she needed to go to
tijuana
and so she went to tijuana she was there
i was taking care of the of the babies
because right now i'm like not trained
very very hard right yet because i don't
have a a fight yet coming soon okay an
official fight
uh so yeah i was in the house but other
other other years we'll try to do
something so sometimes you have to just
be the dad at home with the kids
actually after a fight i'm trying to
spend more time with my daughters yeah
because imagine am i in
my regular days it's like all day on the
train in the gym i
i have like five hours five hours just
training you know maybe not straight
five hours right you know between
sessions i have some rest and then the
other practice
so yeah i don't have too much time for
my kids because when i finish my day i
try to go to my house and spend some
time with my family but obviously i'm so
tired yeah i'm hungry or maybe i'm i'm
diet because i have the fight so oh yeah
it's a lot of different things so you're
not can be just very present exactly but
so when i
when i finished the training camp and i
pas and i finished my the fight
two or three weeks i tried to spend a
really good good time with my family
it's very important for me man yeah
and do you take your family to tijuana
because
do you guys go back over there much or
no yeah yeah like
one one
pair per month we go to tijuana and we
see my parents and everything
when you were growing up over there was
it was it exciting was it dangerous i
just think tijuana seemed like so much
like adventure and things happening all
at the same time was it like that or
what was it like i i would say the same
and i mean
if you want to find problems
uh
you you will man yeah yeah that's cool
you know sometimes i like some problems
you know
maybe i like american problems okay yeah
uh actually
actually it's funny when the the
american people say like ah i'm the
american gangster yeah like okay don't
say that in mexico please because that
is serious because somebody will see if
you really are yeah so yeah but man when
i was a kid and i was growing up there
in tijuana i was i was like going to the
school and then going to the gym uh i
had you know a few friends but i never
like every single weekend going to the
the to the night club or something like
that it was like just
uh
being myself going to the gym to the
school and doing my stuff and yeah so i
never find real problems that's why
that's why when a lot of people ask me
like hey
it's really dangerous
yeah like man i'm not the guy yeah
somebody else is huh and they need to
get more like big people in mexico i
know we kind of were y'all got to get
some big
because what's the biggest mexican they
have
like what like
what is that like the biggest
most grand mecano senor or chica
talking about fame or what no no no like
uh
[Music]
tall distance yeah oh
i mean you can find uh
big people there definitely and they
hide them huh yeah
but it's not normal the regular uh
head of the mexican people is like
uh
five eight five seven even even less wow
yeah that's why all the the famous
mexican boxers are in the small weights
yeah because we are we are small that's
fine that's okay that's good yeah you're
doing great you're doing great
and do you is there an ethnicity that's
the hardest to fight that you have found
because your division has i guess your
division doesn't have a lot of like
white guys in it huh it's more
it's an uh good question i don't know do
you think one ethnicity is tougher than
uh and over your time have you noticed
good question man i'm actually i'm
thinking about the the white guys in in
my division
um
white guys in my division maybe no
damn we need some diversity in there i
know
yes you know afro-american people and
guys from brazil yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i mean
maybe maybe the ethnicity you know i
mean someday i don't remember who say
like hey one day the mexican people will
uh will dominate all these small
divisions yeah
you never you never know we are working
we're working there is martial arts in
in in mexico in the country yeah but
right now i'm the the the only one in
the flyweights well a few new ones are
coming yeah
but right now in like the the biggest
there's some other latino guys but
you're the only mexican guy yeah
do you ever see that movie la bamba did
you see it la bamba yeah of course
it's good
remember that part
man i i was i don't remember the last
time i watched the movie but when i was
a kid
i i don't have like a cable or to watch
like uh other kind of movies yeah
so it was like the the free
television i don't know how you say yeah
yeah
um
the free channels and yeah yeah okay
and in one channel was like a very
popular movie every single weekend they
put la bamba every single every single
weekend
i just watched it like a couple of uh
maybe three months ago it's good man
it's so sad though it's very it's very
uh
of she kind of killed her right like
yeah
it's nice yeah i think so so may did is
there a favorite mexican movie that you
watched growing up no no no no of course
no
uh mexican favorite mexican movie
it's just because i was i was watching
the real mexican uh
uh theater like movies
from mexicans actors and everything so
it's
it's different wow and sometimes um the
american people put the the chicano
culture
like the the the main one
right and
it's not it's not true and yeah i mean
they have like a lot of different things
about mexico like the food and that
stuff like taco bell or something like
this yeah yeah yeah true they live back
i see they do a bad job but the
translation is not good
yeah i love la bamba is nice i mean i'm
not saying this it's about movies it's a
nice movie and they have like despic
i like uh despecable me
this pokemon yeah yeah you like it is is
with the minions
yeah
my daughters love me names oh i love
minions they're funny man they're good
and they were sometimes
some filipino people who remind me of
minions
because they're happy and they just keep
going you know
maybe
no but my daughters loves minions and
it's a nice movie yeah it's good how do
you say this back about despicable me in
spanish oh man i
ah i forget i forget
[Laughter]
i want to tell you that manscaped has
really leveled up their game
now you know a lot of people a lot of
men especially and even women they get
that body hair you look at your crotch
and look like a damn junkyard
look like steve and avery milling around
somewhere by your navel wouldn't be
shocked out there
and he did it even though he didn't do
it but he did it
so what i'm talking about is manscaped
the manscaped lawnmower 4.0 is that
precise trim
their advanced skin safe technology look
you couldn't cut yourself if you tried
man
and don't try
now you can even enhance your perfect
grooming routine with their ultra
premium collection
that that package maybe that includes
the manscape premium deodorant
hydrating body moisturizer body wash two
in one shampoo plus a free gift
christmas is only ten and a half months
away baby
you can get four products plus a free
gift inside the ultra premium collection
hop in the shower take care of
everything
get scaped maybe escape that man or one
man
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code theo at
manscape.com
you can support the podcast get 20
percent off
and free shipping with the code t-h-e-o
at manscape.com that's 20 off in free
shipping with the code theo
manscaped.com the power of attraction is
now in a bottle thanks to manscaped
this podcast is sponsored by better help
if there's something interfering with
your happiness
or that's preventing you from achieving
your goals
sometimes we think it's it's a person or
a or
a job or something like that but
sometimes it's something inside of us
something inside of us that's attaching
to these things that are just uh
more in our day to day life
better help can help they will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours wow
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy done
securely online
i've used better help i was having a
tough time
and uh
and i got masked over the counselor and
i was able to pull over on the side of
the road one time and facetime hey betty
i'm not doing well
visit their website read their
testimonials and visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p join the
over 2 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
special offer for this past weekend
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
let me ask you so
uh
when it comes to the so with fighting
when it comes to the figure
figure figure
figure figure
jesus [ __ ] christ figure it out huh
guy but a lot of people say different
things
every episode it changes the name he
switches the letters man the guy is
cheating and then letters man
um
but do you guys think you can do
is it possible for one of you to knock
the other one out or it's not possible
you think honestly after this after this
much experience
man
i don't know
because i mean
before
or reality i mean fidel was like
like you know oh thank you man
uh so before already valerie he was like
knocking out every single fighter
in the roster
and he was doing a very great job doing
that
yeah but with me i mean
he
he he hit me with
his best punches and
you do you think either one of you can
knock the other do you think you can
knock him like because you guys can
obviously you can both
find a way to win
but is it possible i wonder because you
guys do i mean no i mean the possibility
is always there man you know talking
about myself
i know
i don't have that kind of power to knock
one people out with like cold right i
know that you can work in the gym you
know you can work in your extension
conditioning you can work with your
explosivity and you can work with your
technique and your position oh yeah and
i try to to work within that like every
single time in the gym right but i know
i i don't bore with that [ __ ]
superpower
like just engage your exactly that is
like that is amazing
um phil bourne with that power
but i mean
i don't have that superpower but i have
another one yeah i have a nice chin man
yeah oh yeah
you got an extra chin huh yes i mean who
has it in your family a family member
has it too
i don't know because
my family doesn't have the history of
sports
wow they never play like soccer it's a
regular sport in mexico so they never
play soccer or they never play
nothing man i'm the first one you're
like a surprise huh yeah you know and
then my brother started to to to do a
mixed martial arts too oh he's a
professional too but it's like not like
a real
job for him it's just like he wants he
go to the gym and yeah and do the
exercise and everything
and if he
has the opportunity to fight you do it
if not he's like okay right it's
a hobby it's a hobby for for him so yes
man again
i don't know i have a nice chin uh he
hit me with the his best punches in both
of these guys
i got hurt one time was watching
last five put ice on my neck yeah man
last fight i can recognize he throw me
his best punch in the t round
and he was like a little flashbang but
i was fine
so man the possibility to the knockout
decide was there always because a good
punch is a good punch but
but maybe you can't you guys can't do it
maybe man we have something missed so
something mystic between us
i mean the guy is a horrible person but
yeah do you think he has the same
because his energy is different than
yours
that's why that's why i mean right now i
mean to me this rivalry is is in the
hall of fame of the ufc right now easily
oh yeah do you think that but where does
it go from here because it's like if
there's nowhere really for you to get
like you guys could
i feel like you guys could do this for
five more years you know i could do it
you see
uh 400
you guys are coming out there like this
moreno against
50 i don't know man like i i can do it i
don't care i mean it's not personal it's
for me man i just won the title man
right i just want to be the best but do
you already feel one now once you win
because the title can only be with
somebody for a little while you know i
remember when dustin poirier won the
interim title and i went over to his
house and he had the belt there and it
was crazy it was so cool you know
but everybody kind of every the title
kind of just comes and goes you know
like nobody really gets to keep it
forever maybe khabib retired with it and
some guys do
is that still like the biggest goal or
do your goals kind of shift once you're
at this
because you're kind of in the space
where there's nowhere really to you know
it's just you guys right there
does your goals shift now like do you
have a different
goal do you have a different goal than
maybe you did two years ago
and if so what is it because
i mean
my goal is to be the best yeah you know
and
if i have the veil the people can
recognize who is the best right
but to me yeah i mean it's easy to me
it's it's not the bell
it's just
why i have that belt
you understand that because
tell me more i can see i can see a lot
of like champions and it's fine i mean i
don't i don't have nothing against i'm
against uh
those guys i mean it's fine i understand
because they feel very proud
but a lot of champions like they want
the title and it's like oh i want to
take pictures
every single day with my belt yeah and i
go to every single interview with the
veil
you know yeah yeah dude yeah i feel you
that's not cheerful because they they
love
the people sometimes they love like
souvenirs they love trophies and yeah
that's true i mean to me
it's funny because i remember when i won
the belt uh-huh
well okay helgrel is nice it's pretty
but i went to my house like i lived in
my couch like there yeah
and then
then my wife came with me and said like
hey
you need to put the bell in a nice place
come on like oh i thought she'd be
yelling at you like get your belt out
the living room you know like get your
shoes off
i could do it later it's heavy too the
bell oh it's heavy jesus christ give him
a lighter belt because you just fought
the whole time now you got to carry this
heavy belt out of the ring imagine that
i mean the people because sometimes i
need to go with some uh
with my sp with some sponsor to do
something oh they want to bring the veil
like yeah
that's the six that's the sixth round
right there
oh they want you know the photo shoot
with the veil and the bell is so heavy
like man i don't like this
you won the bell take it i don't i don't
care
well yeah i mean
so for what is the goal still oh because
if if you have the belt then people know
who the champion is yeah that's it yeah
you know and i know and i was asking the
same because the if the people ask me
like hey where's your belt yeah
first of all
i'm not with the bail all the time i'm
not with the bell in my car
and second one
with i mean in that moment with belle or
with not without belt
do you know who is the champion right
like oh yes like
that's it but once you become a champion
don't you feel like at a certain point
you're qualified to always be a champion
though
i wore like a champion every day yeah at
least it's a good attitude it's a good
point you know yeah because yeah
sometimes
talking about me in person i mean
i'm very obsessive are you i feel like
sometimes it's not enough even when i
know i'm so i'm working so hard and i
feel so tired
i go to my way thinking like
maybe i need to work a little bit more
actually the success people
work so hard and they think they don't
they don't work so hard oh they don't
think they work so hard that's
interesting i mean that's and that's
at the same time obviously the the
depression and everything you need to
work with that with your mind because
this is an important thing morning this
is part because julie always in with a
lot of stress and
you
know
yeah it's interesting i think i work all
the time and other people are like man
you work so hard you're doing so well
but me i don't really see it like that
man yes man i sometimes a lot of people
say hey you need to rest like man i
don't know what you
are talking about i mean i need to i
need to do more yeah but at the same
time my body say like no you can't like
i have this bad battlefield in my mind
always yeah
it's tough to it's tough to manage
sometimes i bet at least having a family
and stuff gets you out of your own head
and keeps you course
i mean i was talking with you about my
time with my with my family after
practice after my when my days uh finish
my day yeah and
i know
maybe the time is not the best because
i'm tired and i can i can like play like
two hours without better you have neck
at least i'm trying and you know i spend
time with my family it's nice you know
because my daughters are there very
funny yeah my my big daughter she's like
she's doing like the eight-year-old
she's in the school yeah and she's doing
our uh yujitsu
yeah yeah and she's uh she's a
one street degree oh she's watching
right white belt when she's right oh
yeah same level yes
i'm one strike white belt man but i'm
still i i go like five times a week but
i'm one striped white yeah right now
yeah i mean i mean but that that time
with my families uh distract me today to
my realities
uh we actually have a question let me
this we got some questions that came in
and usually we have television monitors
but since we're not at the studio i'm
just going to play it like this
um and it's actually kind of about what
you're talking about and then
hi brandon and theo my name is melissa
so i am mexican too theo at this point i
think you count as mexican as well
it's a very mexican household um very
traditional
uh women hold this nurturing caregiving
role
and within recent years i've really got
into you know mma fighting following ufc
and i'm interested in taking some
jujitsu classes i have a lot of friends
that are males that are taking classes
right now so my question to brandon is
how do we eliminate these cultural
barriers
so if your daughter were to be
interested in maybe boxing mma fighting
i'm interested in seeing your
perspective and how you would you know
just go about that again thank you so
much
that's a good question it fits yes so is
it
and she may be talking specifically in
mexico that women are looked at more of
like a mother and caregiver
do you think um
that that
it's changing what do you think
or what do you think about women in
getting into jiu jitsu in that country
man i mean
first of all i feel a lot of respect for
all women who's trying to to do this
experiment
because it's a tough sport not just for
a woman and even for a man it's a tough
sport because you need to learn too much
and if you really
want to be a fighter oh you need to pass
for a lot of pain man yeah it's scary
even i mean yeah because
sometimes the people is a little bit
confused
like oh i don't want to do mix much
alarm it looks very aggressive i mean if
you want just to do the sport and
practice and sweat and do some exercise
you can do it i mean you can hit pads
you can
learn technique and that's it i mean
everything changes when you want to be a
fighter definitely because you need to
just you need to do sparring you need to
have the
have the the heart sessions and
everything and for a woman
when you step into an um a gym
a gym
you can see
i don't know
90 percent of the of the team yeah
men's you know yeah
and maybe a few woman's there
and that
in a few minutes i can't i can just
imagine that is like a little bit
intimidation
some intimidation there so starting from
that
i have a lot of
respect for for for her right because
it's it's hard man so
i don't know i have the example of my of
my daughter yeah like hey hey girl i
mean you need to go to do something
because you know this self self-defense
it's a good weapon in your life you
never know
you know oh yeah even me just going i
feel like now if somebody came and
wanted to knock me out i wouldn't be as
scared to get knocked out okay whereas
before i'd be scared to get knocked out
but now at least if i i'm just like all
right
you know i just it's like a little less
fear i don't know just little things um
yeah your confidence goes up yeah i mean
and she's a little princess man i don't
feel like she want to be like blackville
uh a competitor i you know i i don't
feel like she wanted to do that in the
future but at least i mean get your blue
belt get your purple bale and get that
uh knowledge in your mind and that's it
you know
um what so do you think and what about
in mexico is it getting popular for
women there is it not is it not that big
of a thing there or in tijuana you know
i mean right now in in in entrance gym
in tijuana they have an a decent uh
female team oh wow you have like uh four
or five girls and it's not too much
right because the
the
the team the whole team is like
40 50 guys
wow it's crazy
what's what's the what's the there's a
there's a there's a there's a
predominantly it seems like mexican uh
or latino like uh
um
it's like ufc or bellator but it's at
night time i see it on television
sometime you know what i'm talking about
it's like a league
it's like a fight league
but it's mostly i think mexican
um
i mean yeah
it's a smaller one it's like a bellator
but it's very small you know i mean
that's something i'm a scene
where you see it at night on television
at night sometime late at night i see it
all i mean they have a few ones like uh
is a uwc actually that league is from
uwc you were in it i i fought there
before yeah yeah when i started fighting
pro like a professional i fought there
yeah and the league is from it's from
the entrance gym tijuana
um it's a nice link because they put a
lot of guys in the contender series and
a lot of guys
got the contract from
from contender series and yeah fall into
ufc so it's like in a nice league it's
another one uh uh luke's filings another
one he's in five past two
i think those
those ones are the more solid leagues in
mexico right now yeah yeah
what's your um other kids like do they
have hobbies or other daughters what are
they oh they're like young oh they're
wrong my middle daughter is three years
right now oh she's she don't know
my my
my youngest daughter she's one year
one year and a few months so they don't
know nothing like that it's just just
there's bantamweight huh yeah just
getting fun in the house all day yeah
just having fun huh yeah
my daughter she started to do something
because you mean she's she said she
started man i remember when she was two
three years and now she's like i wanna
do this and the other day i was talking
with my with
with my wife hey i wanna go to the mall
because
oh come on
girl now you wanna go to the mall
damn
where would you guys go hang out what
was like a fun thing do you remember
like in school or something when you
were growing up like dude was there a
fun place would you guys go to the mall
stuff like that as kids yeah
in mexico mexico yeah
me
not too much i mean some i i went to the
mall for because they the theater was
the movie theater was there so yeah with
my mom and everything
uh
i remember the weekends i i went with my
with my parents to some restaurant to
something
again the movie theater um do they have
in a like in america like aliens are
like a big thing do they have that in
mexico like do people talk about aliens
and stuff same or no aliens you know
what i'm talking about aliens the guys
in
in the air yeah yeah yeah in the other
yeah
i guess they're bad guys they always
make them to be like kind of bad guys
you know what it's not my world but yeah
of course definitely
needs to be some guys talking about
aliens but is it popular in mexico
because in america i feel like people
always yeah
no i don't like america wow why do we
care so much
i don't know man
and maybe i'm i'm talking from myself my
own experience
other guys like man come on islands are
very popular in mexico i don't know i
don't know man to be honest it's not my
it's not my goal to know too much about
aliens yeah
what do you think about aliens they
exist or not
i wouldn't be surprised you know we got
it
but we got a lot of issues already kind
of
my friend told me a lot of black people
and aliens don't get along someone tell
me one time okay which is crazy you know
but i didn't know so i think a lot of
stuff i'm just learning it you know but
i always wondered because i've only
grown up in america i always wondered if
people in other countries have the same
like do they care about aliens you know
okay and they have surprise parties in
mexico like a surprise birthday you know
what i'm talking about yeah
depends you know everybody hides and
they come in yeah
sometimes my my wife give me like a few
uh builders or surprise birthdays
sometimes oh yeah before and what's nice
yeah is it is everything about uh
traditions different yeah the traditions
and in other
families yeah
yeah family's so important in mexico
what things do you think that you enjoy
more about mexico as compared to america
are there any things you kind of notice
about the
like we say like we said before i think
the love
yeah people laugh more in mexico yeah
the latinos [ __ ] laughter yeah i mean
in america i mean there are nice basic
people too but they they are a little
bit a little bit more like cold
yeah sometimes
in in
the latin american culture is like
i don't know i mean for example if you
have like
like two years you don't see your family
and you go with them to visit your you
know your family like wow they make a
party and a lot of food like they're
gonna
lose everything
like it's a big deal it's nice wow
um
so yeah that's yeah in america it's just
like you give hugs and then you go maybe
it's not it's not everybody is it's
always we are talking in general right
right right but
yeah the
latin american culture is like very
i don't know it's because i don't know
the the word
in in in english but in spanish is
allegre alegre alegre like happy
allegra
it sounds good yeah allegra i later like
like happy like yeah happy happiness
yeah like maybe happiness or celebratory
um
yeah i just always feel like latinos are
having a better time sometimes i'm happy
that i'm born here but sometimes i wish
sometimes i had more
of a diff like i wish you get to live in
more culture actually i mean
i have this guy because i was watching
his videos he's a a kind of youtuber
uh a kind of because he do like
conference and everything what his name
is uh
jokoy kenji yoko so he's his father he's
japanese and his mother is from colombia
ooh that's a good mix huh
so
in
his conference he talked about the
difference of cultures
you know
the japanese culture is like very
serious very very serious thank you very
much
very disciplined
they never go late to no so early
they sleep outside
early early in the job
is very they are hard workers and
everything yes work work work stress
very serious yeah and the colombian
culture is like very happy culture a lot
of food like labor exactly the dance
but sometimes it's not the
the hard work is not the representation
oh it's more party exactly so
he talked about that like hey when i go
to japan
because they have all these
uh high
numbers of swiss sites yeah uh-huh
so he he go to japan and talk about the
latin culture like hey
some sometimes it's funny did you go
late
relax just relax
spend time with your friends okay and
he went to colombia hey you need to do
do you need to go early do your job come
on
you need a briefcase exactly maybe it's
a similar with america and oh yeah
that's probably true man
yeah i wonder sometimes like yeah just
how much it would be nice to probably be
have a little bit more of different
culture in me and stuff like that um we
got another question that came in right
let's go
one to ask the question i mean she just
need to find a a nice
gym with a lot of respect and
work hard that's it
question for brandon what is your number
one advice for winning a street fight
and do you have any stories
ganga
yeah
where is you become a fighter then
people want to fight you that's probably
one of the problems of being a fighter
like if you if you want to be a
nobody wants to eat your cookies until
you say you're a baker you know what i'm
saying brother but then once you
once they see that oven open people want
to come and see what's up they want a
snickerdoodle my first advice is don't
fight the street
it's horrible
you have a lot of scratching your elbows
in your knees
um you don't win nothing yeah you don't
stop for the cars it's not glory it's
not glory there man right
i i have just won a street fight in all
my life i had
15 or 16 years old
and i went to play soccer to some field
and we always playing there and some guy
from he looks like very like from the
hood like
even a kind of homeless really yeah
exactly he looks weird like yeah
he looks with problems yeah and he
starts to play with problems
and he start to play to play
[Laughter]
with yeah yeah he looked it for a long
time he started to play with us soccer
we all the guys he he came with a few
with our few friends i remember like one
or two i don't know
and we start to play and everything
and at some point he has the ball
and i take the the ball from his legs
and he start to get mad because i i was
doing that like cons constantly yeah
okay and in the last one i take the ball
he's here i i had the ball and he's
tried to take me the the ball like bad
like
oh slide you down exactly but i move the
ball there and he's just like a slide on
all the ground like a cartoon exactly
and then he
you go against me like he started to
scream to my face and everything
so i i saw the the problem there and
like when i put my hands up i don't i
don't care i in that moment i i had like
two or three years experience of or
mixed martial arts
and
and then i put my hands up he he put his
hands up
and he started to move a little bit
everybody man if i throw a job
and with the job he went to the ground
i don't remember if he started to
throw some blood but yeah maybe i don't
remember but i remember he went to the
ground like boom
and i don't feel good man i don't i feel
like
because when i fought when i fight with
some guy who
uh i know the guy know how to fight
right and i beat him like okay that's
different it's fair yeah like okay so is
it because you think it's more fair yeah
right yeah because i don't i don't feel
good when i do that like right i
remember that i i saw the guy in the
ground like oh man that's fine i don't i
don't want more promise man everything
is fine and then can i go out of the of
the field and i went to my house and i
feel weird like i don't know i don't
i don't and he didn't couldn't even go
to his house because he was
he was probably homeless you know maybe
he couldn't even go to this house
he couldn't even go after oh oh so yeah
myself so for you fighting there's
something so you you really like to
fight if it's a very organized and it's
fair
yeah okay
so it's not for you you don't like to
because it's interesting some guys just
love to [ __ ] fight like i talked with
cheeto very he just loved guys he's
crazy he's crazy right yeah he knows
he's being crazy he loves [ __ ] you
know he's just he loves to fight you
know and like poirier i think sometimes
he like he loves to scrap too but i
think he likes to fight he wants to
prove himself kind of like um but so you
like to fight why do you like to fight
you think
for the same the same with like like
prayer
i like to prove i i love
when the people
when i
i watch people from now from the school
you know from high school from middle
school
and like hey
i never thought you you would be a
fighter a real fighter wow
like
i love that because
i proved they they were they were wrong
in case you haven't heard car and home
insurance rates are going up this year
yeah they are
every year
you know everything it's all
you know life they charge you for it
well make sure you're not paying more
than you need to tune to the zebra they
can help you find the perfect insurance
for your needs in just minutes
the zebra compares car and home quotes
for every major insurance company side
by side
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision
so if you're not sure if you're paying
the right amount you're paying too much
don't lay there in bed
and wonder damn are they jacking me for
another 30
or then bastards sneaking another
eighteen dollars out of my pocket find
out
the zebra
saves people an average of nine hundred
and twenty two dollars a year
on car and home insurance combined
and they do it all in just five minutes
insurance man i wonder all the time am i
getting screwed
now you can find out
save time and money in minutes
go to the zeb the zebra.com
theo
you can support the show
by going to this special url the
zebra.com
slash t-h-e-o and get your free quote
today
don't spend more than you need to the
zebra.com theo
all right
everybody want them blue uh weiner
lifters baby i'm talking about blue
chews
blue chews
damn bro
dude a bl you know a starfish
a starfish was just a jellyfish and then
somebody gave it a blue chew
damn think about that
that's the power of that popper baby
the power of that popper
blue chews tablets combat all forms of
erectile dysfunction and help men gain
extra confidence for when it's time to
perform
now i've take i look i've tasted oh heck
some i don't mind the top i like it you
know i'm saying dude look if you put a
dish up by the television hell i
probably have half i probably have i'd
have half a handful you know i wouldn't
be able to stand up or all i'd be able
to do is stand up but it'd be hard for
me to probably bend my appendages to get
anywhere after that
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online
no doctors no sneaky stuff nothing like
that
make it discreet take care of your
uh what you need for your sex
that's it
here's a special deal for you guys try
blue chew free when you use our promo
code theo at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code
t-h-e-o to receive your first month for
free
bluechew.com promo code theo
did you know that you were going to be
that much of a fighter though no i'm
starting the sport just for love just to
do something just i was a showy kid
right so i'm stu i i i remember when i
finished my elementary school i was on
vacations
uh like
a few weeks before to to go to the
middle school i was talking with my mom
like hey with my parents and hey i want
to do something you know i have too much
time you know i remember my times in in
elementary school like too much
i was finishing my my day in school and
then like start to to eat uh junk food
oh yeah and though and then go to my
room and start to play video games yeah
and that's it
so at some point was like i'm done with
that like i want to do something like
some sport
in the fight i was playing a lot of uh
combat
games
so like taken was my yeah fighting games
fighting games and like i want to do i
want to practice something like i want
to do uh capoeira i remember because one
of the other characters of the game wow
yeah
eddie i remember the name uh
one of his things was picking up his
style was the capoeira so i love this i
love the style for that but my mom never
find a good place in tijuana to do
capoeira but
we find the the mixed martial arts
in that moment um
they say baletodo
valetoro yeah like baletudo in brazil
yeah like no rules something like that i
don't i forget the name in
like that was the place was called that
i i mean in the mexico in general right
you know for the culture for the
paleturo and then was a new sport in the
in the country in that moment was 2006.
it was a new sport yeah oh
so
and you just liked it you just kept
doing it yeah i saw everything the
information like brazilian you get to
kick boxing wrestling like what i don't
know what is
wrestling yujitsu i don't know what is
grizzly but all the information looks
like nice yeah so my my mom got the
the number
and they signed you up that was a
weekend like saturday sunday and next
monday i went to the class and you stay
committed huh
i mean it's very simple man right was
very my style was very simple was like
that and then i mean i was just training
because i i love to spend time there in
the gym sweating doing exercise my body
looks better right yes confidence
more confidence in the middle school you
start to meet some girls and you start
you want to look better
exactly you want to dance
but then i mean i started to watch like
man i like to do this like i don't want
to do nothing more
but did did people just look at you like
a karate boy they're like oh it's just a
karate boy
maybe
and then later it became a bigger thing
exactly
and did you was there a point where you
were thinking about not doing it anymore
at some point like what like where you
think when you're when your career was
kind of because your career's been like
this you know and it's definitely
very it's in a new space uh and has been
for a few years now but did you think
when it was
did you reconsider or not reconsider but
i think maybe i'm finished
a lot of times man that's a normal
question in a in a light of a fighter
yeah i i
i'm good on this like because what i i
remember when i started my professional
career my amateur career was amazing
like a lot of the brazilian tournaments
winning
i had a nice amateur record of
kickboxing i have 12 and two something
like that my my
mma my amateur career was very nice too
like six and i know i have one dress
something like that but my amateur
career was a success
but when i do my transition to uh to the
professional
i was like winning one losing another
one winning one my my record
what sorry my record went to three and
three
and the problem was i was very young
i i remember i am three and three boy
anything could happen you know i might
he might not make the playoffs you know
man my
my fierce fight
was when i had uh 17 years old
and
man if you can watch me now i mean i
know i'm not the most muscular guy in
the room right now
i'm not going to fight you i know that
i promise but imagine at 17 years old i
was like a skinny real no tattoos like i
was looks like a kid man
like a kid
so my opponent my opponents the the most
part of the time was like bigger guys
like 20 something my i remember my first
fight the other guy had
like
25 27. something like that around that
and how old was you uh
17. jesus christ that's illegal i think
yeah so for example my
and that's why i won the next one i
fought with with some guy
he has like
uh
21 or 22 but the guy was a
a guy who was working in construction
and everything yeah strong big
and i was i was very frustrated because
i remember like saying to me like
i know like
talking about technique
i'm a huge better
better than this guy yeah right the
problem is i don't have the power to
show it right right well the weight
class was probably so different as well
huh i was playing in 135 and what was
the guy in
he was in 135 too the construction
worker of course and he was obviously
couldn't wait and everything i i i went
to that fight in
by something like that
and the other guys i don't know
so yeah i mean what about also a lot of
jockeys coming out of y'all's country oh
what is jackie's yakis you know or yakis
i don't know why jackie's like the um
the um
[Music]
you know this guy you know like uh we
had we had a
um
uh
mario gutierrez i think
well i know is
he like you know the caballeros you know
they
okay okay the uh horses on the horseback
yeah yeah you know i'm talking about it
okay it's big in mexico there's a lot of
a lot of jockeys or yuckys
maybe it's not my world man so i don't
know
but you never met any no oh for example
you talk about people who just love to
ride on the horse you know
maybe the people with money because
horses
yeah horses expensive huh canelo has a
a horse's place like you've been over
there no no but i can see his social
media and the picture and everything
like wow that's amazing so yeah i mean
it's not my world but
but i mean there's a lot of ranch there
in in mexico so yeah
and you said a lot of people are moving
over there a lot of americans now are
moving over to mexico to te juana i mean
man the border
in
san diego tijuana is crazy every single
day man both directions now both
direction now
before it was just going to to the
united states yeah now
the people from san diego who was trying
to cross the border to tijuana
is crazy too man they spent like one two
hours there so yeah i mean i was talking
with you a lot of people from from san
diego you know american people yeah um
so they they work in san diego but they
live in in tijuana because they are
winning dollars right they are spending
pesos in tijuana in mexico so imagine
that they can spend more because
everything is cheaper in tijuana right
the thing is they need to cross the
border every day right and man i mean i
had a neighbor who
he was like every single morning like
i don't remember like 3 a.m 4 a.m like i
was hearing his car turning on his car
going to the border and man because it
takes a long time like i mean like you
say before before to start with with
this like i mean they are winning money
but they are losing life man i mean
that's too many too much time yeah
you're sitting in the car you can't do
nothing am i in all the stress
everything like smoke you probably start
smoking chewing gum
i don't know what i would like that
for two hours i don't even lose my mind
huh everybody is tijuana changing a lot
because there are a lot of people moving
there
man tijuana rhino is growing up
like too much like
and the space is every single
time
not enough not enough so they are
building a lot of
they are
doing buildings
so the the seed is going up wow
you can see a lot of buildings a lot of
condos apartments everything so yeah i
mean because again a lot of people from
latin america they went to tijuana
trying to cross the border to the united
states they can't so they oh yeah huh
honduran they stuck
in in tijuana
they came with everything with the
culture with the traditions so yeah i
mean talking about
tijuana it's an
it's an a weird but nice mix of cultures
wow yeah because it's getting diverse
and who else is there there we were
talking about um
people from uh
honduras you said the last ones uh from
my tea
uh i don't know how you say in english
high tea oh yeah like uh like from the
caribbean yeah the caribbean yeah yeah
yeah yeah they have witchcraft
witchcraft it's like a
sorcerer sorcery sorcery yeah like uh
magic in haiti ah okay and our haiti we
say haiti also haiti but they have
witchcraft and magician like magic dark
arts okay
yeah so i mean now you can see artistico
pellegroso yeah i mean i don't know if
sometimes you know for the language i
don't i don't understand sometimes so
hopefully it's not racist but you can
see now a lot of black people walking in
in tijuana no it's not right
but you wouldn't see it before no no no
no it's different yeah
and that's
haitian people yeah yeah and now like
people from honduras because a lot of
people like go back to honduras but
other people stay there
wow
tijuana is getting diverse huh yes man
it's it's crazy i love the city man yeah
a lot of people say i'm like an
ambassador of the city yeah i mean do
you get in like a armored car when
you're there or anything you have
security or now or no if you go there no
yes
yeah have you got to meet the president
or anything yet of mexico yes man i
really i did it the last the last year
man no
and right now gary
it's it's awkward this is weird because
you went to the capitol yes i went to
the capital of mexico mexico city yeah
yeah mexico city heart is beautiful it's
beautiful a lot of nice places but it's
too much people there really a lot of
people you can see a lot of people in
the street trying to cross the the
street or something waiting for the the
light and a lot of people oh it's like
200 people were er er waiting in the
corner uh-huh
it's like the nature channel exactly so
yeah i mean last year i i went to to the
capitol to meet the president
was weird because
first of all you you had to bring the
bell too or no yes oh my gosh yeah i
mean the people love soberness the the
people love trophies
jesus christ so can you just throw a
picture of it
take it let the guys leave it in the car
it's heavy i know
so we i wake up in the morning i eat my
breakfast
and then we went to the
on the front stuff
and
yeah but we we went to the back from the
back okay because in the front it's like
too much people watching everything so
oh it's fancy it's like uh tourists
so
wow in the
the back part of the
national a lot of security
a lot of people with suits a lot of
police officers
a lot of media outside and then you
cross some like uh
ducross
some kind of border um like a bridge or
ah no no like a security
okay
you cross that and you go to another
security he was getting your name and
your your id and everything you have to
take the belt and put it in the basket
each time uh-huh no of course yes yeah
you need to pass that but you need to
pause it should you pass the bell for a
metal metal security thing
uh and nothing was just wait for him
like 20 minutes because he was doing
something i don't remember what and then
i met him and it's weird because and you
knew who he was yeah yeah i i know the
guy um is we're in mexico right now the
the
the government in mexico is very like
fragmented exactly i mean it's the same
thing like with donald trump oh wow
because a lot of people love him and a
lot of people hate him right
you know
so it's the same in me so yeah i i
before to to when i
when i knew i wanted to go to meet the
president i wanted to be the president
um i was like man
i don't know if this is a good idea
because i love haters like ah now you
are with the government
but man i mean i was trying to be very
very neutral like man i'm going to do
this for for the mixed martial arts in
my country i mean that's a really good
meeting the president of a country
any for any country i think it's
interesting you know so it's just an
honor it doesn't matter who it is
exactly exactly just the honor to be
there yeah
so yeah i mean at the end of the day i
think that people underst understood
that yeah i think so it makes sense to
me a nice experience man it was yeah wow
so what is for what what aspirations do
you have right now do you feel like is
there a way where you feel like you
obviously get back to the belt is that a
goal right now up to 100 percent it is i
was i'm pushing so hard with my manager
like man i don't want another fightman i
want that fight because i know
that i mean first of all
i still thinking i won that fight yeah
yeah look man
i would agree i would agree that i don't
know if he won
okay
you know uh
i don't think that he i don't believe
that he did enough to win
that's where i stand with it
man so
i'm just trying to keep a balance
between
i started fight
i feel like i won the fight
and and i want to be very positive about
it
and at the same time i don't want to be
cocky
and say like oh i want a fight i don't
need to learn nothing about it because i
want and i don't want to be that
stupid guy yeah okay because that guy's
not learning anything exactly
so
man i'm trying to
watch the perspective of the churches to
see how what they can maybe
is
watching that fight and
you know fix my mistakes and that's it i
mean i i know for sure i just need to
fix a little things
well it's also interesting and i heard
you say this on another podcast talking
about the perspective of the judges
because some of them don't know that
much about wrestling about doing uh mma
they don't [ __ ]
i don't even know some of them i don't
even know what business they're in you
know that's important i mean a lot of
guys from boxing yeah
because they are a little bit old like
judging
on a
whole different sport right oh yeah well
you don't notice sometimes like yeah
position is so important one certain
like hook of the foot or
or keeping an arm out of the way like
things like that are so strategic and
they can shape around it seems like my
point was
i mean ease
the guy
throw three good punches in all the in
all the fights he he got three
knockdowns against me
and he was throwing a good kick he
tried a few takedowns in the fight he
never take me down really he take me
down one time but was my fault because i
closed too much distance and just he
just took the advantage and he did it
okay that's my point but my point is man
i was touching his face every single day
you know like a musician huh like tommy
lee man i know i i i don't have the
enough power to knock a guy like cold
but i mean i'm doing my job oh you like
put it on the refrigerator effect
effective punches straight to his to his
face everything
yeah what else could you look i i i
don't think that the title should have
changed hands man i really don't think
that it should have i wonder sometimes
you wonder if it's there doing something
because of the story
they want this bigger picture story but
you know what
actually
right now i'm very excited excited man
yeah because i feel like i put a little
bit more drama in all of this
and at the same time i'm a little bit
mad with me like man that belt is yours
man and now
you wake up some monster inside me man
yeah i like that huh some chupacabra
supercars oh
so man i don't know man it is
interesting at least your story now has
enough cause that's your story your
story is this yeah that's your story it
is so it's almost like
we can't be shocked when we get our
story you know we can't be surprised
it's like that's what god has for us he
has that story it's like your story is
that you are
a guy who has to face at certain
adversities everybody is and that's the
way that yours goes that's interesting
man but yeah i'm sure you have more you
certainly have more purpose the guy the
guy coming wanting something always has
more purpose
and you know what man and it's exciting
it is exciting you know what i mean
i mean i'm i'm very
honest with with everybody about this
like i'm start this
like an in a selfish way
like i'm starting this because i wanna i
wanna be the best yeah i wanna prove
something to the world who say and i'm
not enough uh
uh good to be the best in this in this
sport uh i you know
stupid things like i want a huge house i
want a nice car everything starts from
there from the
selfish way but then for you for me
exactly but then
you know
a lot of people start to come to my
journey you know my wife
my daughters my family
then you start to watch if you do a nice
and a nice job in this you can do
something for the mixed martial arts in
order country right you are motivating a
lot of kids
yeah mexico to do this sport
who watch brandon moreno like hey i mean
i want to be that guy i want to be brand
new i'm not even batman i mean
even probably for halloween they had
people that were running moraine
now
i can see i i can move the world man i
can move and that is a huge motivation
for me man it's a good point it's
powerful and it's almost
i think it starts to become for some
guys in the all's business i notice it
with dust and i notice it with certain
guys
you can do
you won't you get to a level as a human
where you can do it with or without the
sport even
i think i'm not saying that now i'm not
saying i i just think you know sometimes
you start to transcend people see who
you are as a human through the fighting
you know and that's what's sometimes
really
what also people gravitate towards yeah
but and you know the people sometimes
they they forget i mean
i'm a human i know how to fight right
that's a fact
but i'm a human being as like as you as
the other guys right
and
it's
and that
i think is why the people get some
motivation because i'm always i'm always
very good with everybody like man
i'm born in tijuana in a in a hood
you know definitely i understand
the opportunities of other people is are
different
i maybe had a better opportunity to
other people who was trying to do this
the same way
i understand a lot of people they they
don't they
they don't get the success in the future
right
that's a fact no right some people don't
get the same success or the same future
some people don't get the same
opportunity some people get to live
vicariously through your opportunity
some sometimes there's a guy maybe who
wanted to wanted to train or wanted to
do this or that it could be a guy that's
in a wheelchair it could be a guy that
is uh
just got his wife his girlfriend
pregnant young and had to start beating
him
and they see you it's like
it's almost like they it's like oh that
guy
a little whatever i what i wanted to
have a chance at he got a chance at and
they're not angry they are just they
they i think can relate you know
yeah man so
but man at the end of the day to me it's
about
hard work
okay obviously it's about decisions
about how you manage your life
and the possibilities of your own world
but to me it's hard work man
i'm i
i really believe if you live in this
position with hard work maybe you don't
you don't go to here but man you're here
and you have your hard work putting here
i mean that is a success man do you
think that that comes to you from is do
you think that that is a traditionally a
mexican trait or do you think that that
is something that was learned by your
instilled by your parents or do you just
feel like it's just who you are kind of
it's mexicans we started talking that
mexican people work [ __ ] hard dog i
don't even know when mexican people
sleep when i see maggie
mexican people are the hardest i wake up
every day and i go like this round of
applause for mexican people for keeping
the country going that's why i mean to
me it's this combination is hard work
your decisions
and and your world your opportunities
okay
because yeah it's obviously it's not
just about the hard work yeah
okay because i know a lot of people who
cross the border trying to get in a
better life for his for their family and
work all his life but
they never do nothing like they they
don't save money or they don't you know
so they that is about the decisions and
another thing is you know the
opportunities around you you know
when you were growing up did you know
anybody that went and snuck all across
the border did you know any were there
people like that because i'm sure that
or people that
you know came you know like
because a lot of people sneak across
right i mean that's just happens over
there you know tons of people have done
it over the years do you ever is that a
popular thing where people go and then
send money back because you hear about
it from here but you don't i don't know
what it's like in tijuana you know
hmm
um man i don't know because
you never saw that world really much
not exactly no in my around my family i
mean i have too much history i have uh
of uh family in los angeles
for example and but i'm i'm not sure if
they are illegal or not right right yeah
i don't think half the people in los
angeles know that they're legal or not
so i think they're they're illegal i
don't i i'm badly sure you're right
right yeah
so i don't know i mean before across the
border was easy man you needed to say
like oh i'm american citizen you need to
speak and speak like a decent english
and that says you can cross the border
oh yeah but then
after the
the september 11th
the borders everything
are very very uh
disciplined
uh borders right it's hard to cross the
border you need to have your visa the
the the officers are very like watching
everything so you can you can't cross
the border like easy as before it's
tighter yeah
and they have um
and now they have people crossing the
other way that's the craziest thing to
me is that there's now people leaving
america to go live in mexico not that
it's
not a great thing to do but it's just
it's just times change you know yeah i
mean i can i can imagine
it's in the other border cities
like you know for example the the father
of my wife my wife fought the fathers
your father-in-law your you know your
your wife's dad uh-huh yes he he lives
he do the same like he lives in in
tamaulipas
but he worked in laredo
so it's the same
um
i'm gonna go to el paso you ever been
there
just i passed there yeah yeah i know and
i don't stuck there like a little bit
because i needed to go to sia juarez oh
you went to paris yeah i went to juarez
this water is cool it's nice
it's a hard place man it is it's a hard
place it's a lot of aquila doors there
huh i think so i i i was there like two
days or something like that because i
was doing something with my visa and a
lot of what um
criminals
or no maybe crime
i don't know right now but like a few
years
pandas
bandidos bandidos it's
dude you could be a bandito maybe one
day off or just for halloween maybe
maybe man
well yeah man i mean i forget what what
i was saying oh it's okay dude it's
podcasting you can forget i know that's
why i i
and then another a conversation is
coming so i everybody say yeah no
probably we got two more little
questions here and then we'll get you
out of here brenda man um
here's one that came in
what's up theo what's up brandon my name
is adrian i'm from el paso texas the
question is for
brandon where do you see
uh the sport of mma
um from where it was a couple years ago
in mexico to where it is now all across
the country and what do you think the
ufc is doing um to advance the sport in
not only mexico but for all latinos and
all across uh
the latin countries
um big up to both of you
congrats on all your accomplishments uh
you make us very proud brandon go back
and get that uh belt on the fourth time
around gang gang let's go that's cool
yeah what do you think is happening with
this ufc doing stuff in mexico you think
to bran
broadway
gmc
has a few projects in mexico right now
we we had like
two or three years where
the relation between
ufc and latin america was like not the
best because
everything started with the first
developer program
from
ufc in latin america okay so they went
to mexico city
and they may gonna uh like trials
for a lot of latin fighters okay guys
from argentina guys from colombia a lot
of different fighters right different
countries in latin america went to
mexico city and they
and i remember the matchmakers of ufc
was there and they started doing like
hitting paths
doing a jiu-jitsu roles with other guys
like showing all the the skills right
the skills of the region exactly and
then you have to pick uh 12
fighters
to go
to albuquerque new mexico
to jackson's mma yeah
the ufc was paying everything like
paying the gym paying the food
to 12 um
fighters to develop the
the skills of the fighters right and did
you have a chance to be in that or no so
that's the first the first generation of
that developer program
was uh were 12 12 guys
then the in the
in the
first six months yeah they caught six
guys oh [ __ ] exactly leave six guys
there in new mex in albuquerque
and they bring another six guys and that
was you and that was me one of the guys
was me
and they did you live together in a
house yeah was it fun or not
you know it wasn't a and a little
no
it was herman to be honest
and you have bunk bed too yeah oh it
wasn't snoring
a little apartment in the gym
living with 12 guys oh this is christo
like everybody was like like this like
but i mean choking each other yeah i
know but i don't care man i was like i
was there to get new knowledge and
get better and train with other
different people so they did that
program do they still do a lot of
programs like that or is it growing i'm
sure people just seeing you will help it
grow so that
uh
with those guys from the the developer
program
they
made the fierce the ultimate final latch
in america okay
okay so
everything starts from there from that
developer program and that the ultimate
fighter
they made
two more seasons
and they made
two more developer programs oh so the
other developer problem was in an
american top thing and the last one was
in in king's mma in los angeles
so a lot of guys started to go to to ufc
but then something happened they stopped
with the better programs they stopped
with their
ultimate fighter
and
if you wanted to go to the gypsy was
like oh i don't have nothing to show
because it's not like the matchmaker is
is going to the mexican promotions to
watch the talent there i see right so
there was no way to really be seen
exactly so what's what's hard but but
now with the title
i feel like the connection
with between ufc and latin america
uh start to work again so last year
after the title a lot of guys from
fernando from ajim in in tijuana
they went to the contender series oh
it's cool uh-huh
and actually my minor was a really huge
help for that too
so they they fought the contender series
everybody get the contract and now they
are um
jeff's fighters wow that's awesome and
then
the next contender series is coming and
for sure i know other guys from from
antrim from aegean that they are going
to the contender series so there's a
huge connection and you know entering
gym has a lot of different
fighters from different from different
countries a lot of guys from argentina
from
peru from ecuador and that's in hindi
and tijuana exactly so right now i mean
the interim is the the most
the most
biggest gym
in latin america in latin america
wow so far i need to go i need to go to
tijuana maybe for vacation huh man a lot
of food man a lot of
nightlife balance a lot of uh discos huh
definitely yeah so yeah man i love the
quantum and it's a nice place i gotta go
man
i'm gonna have to get you to go there
yeah man maybe i'll get me a good
mexican wife huh do you like hey you
never know i could use it i need someone
to get me going you know go do this some
fun in your life yeah i need that
is it fun having a mexican wife man i
mean
again my wife is your wife is kind of
american but she's mexican she's mexican
she's mexican she lives always all if
you're alive in in oh she's in mexico so
yeah
yeah yeah i think i would like to branch
out and do that man go there i mean if
you love tacos man you can find
good tacos everywhere yeah but after i
have some tacos i gotta do something
else you know oh of course yeah but then
what maybe start a company or something
maybe yeah maybe a small company doing
what though bought this company
marijuana company said
man you know you know what they the
marijuana there in
in mexico is outcast companies said i
think you said pot
oh no i say podcast
marijuana
i mean it's weird in mexico because it's
very close to be legal man so illegal
it's very very close wow
so a lot of marijuana mexican marijuana
companies or even from the united states
they're like like just waiting just
waiting like when this legal like the
start to all the the stores there so
it's it's funny how all the cbd
companies are just waiting to turn like
a everything company wow
yeah it could happen soon huh do you you
don't smoke drugs you said no
to be honest not
um maybe in the future
you never know yeah maybe when you get
older
if you're like a grandfather are you
sitting there i mean i'm not interested
man i'm i mean a lot of people smoke
marijuana and i don't i don't care i
mean i don't have any
any problem with the marijuana
um i use a lot of cbd and sometimes when
i'm like very like sore i smoke cbd
sometimes yeah yeah i've seen this
i feel like i just feel like i don't
need the thc in my life yeah i don't use
it yeah you're kind of good in the space
that you're in
that and i just have this did you
whenever you were growing up did you
guys have any pets at y'all's house or
no i'm just wondering do a lot of
mexican people have pets or not i have
just one dog oh yeah
yeah and i mean i'm trying to do
i mean right now so
my friends they are i have two friends
two training partners living with me in
the house and they they take care of of
my dog because i mean right right now
i'm like
traveling too much and then before was
the training camp and
you know i need to spend time with my
family i need to take care of my
daughter so
the pet is a kind of another kid
so i don't i don't have too much time to
spend too much time with with with the
dog
um
but that said i mean i'm trying to to do
the enough for for him to the dog be
happy right is he happy dog you think
yeah what's his name
pepe is his name oh wow
pepe
and i don't know if the the mexican
culture love to get pets i feel like the
american culture loves to get like
batman ridiculous i have a lot of
friends like oh i have four pets four
dogs in my house like oh my goodness i
know i have birds people have birds
canary
snakes he have snakes
what else ellie some people get
everything alligators goats do you like
pets or not i like goats
what is goats goats is like a little bit
of like a it looks like a sheep but
that's been maybe doing drugs you know
like a ghost oh okay yeah i understand
yeah of course the people have
people goats yeah man america yeah
yeah i think we have a lot more pets
here in america i wonder why
yeah when i was growing up they had dogs
in the street it wasn't indoor dogs
people just have a neighborhood have a
dog you know okay you just see a dog get
bit by the dog whose dog nobody knows
she's [ __ ] gone bro he's a criminal
you know he's just [ __ ] snuck off you
know he's dangerous bro
um so with the fighting man is there any
the only fight you really are going to
take is uh friggito man that's it i mean
afraid
i don't know david i i understand
everybody i understand they keep doing
it with the letters
so
man i mean it's not another fight you're
gonna take isn't it i just want to push
hard for the for the fourth one yeah
i'll watch seven of them i don't keep
doing it i mean and the thing is that i
mean every single fight is so
entertaining
i mean he has
in in the last three fights between us
he has two two bonus performance bonus
but for uh fight of the night i have and
i have three so every single fight was
so good so good and i think it's the i
mean the people can watch and they
want to watch the four one i know the
company won the fourth one and so right
now i'm just
like pushing hard for the four one
that's it and obviously if something
happened in the future and and they say
like no you need to fight with another
guy like we'll we'll be like i will a
little bit mad in that in that moment
but
i mean i just want to fight right yeah
yeah yeah um
cool dude well thank you so much for
coming in man we wish you obviously wish
you the best of luck thank you man just
cool man and yeah if if you guys need
another person over there in mexico
let me know don't if you go to tijuana
uh talk with me and we can go i need
something good okay and we can
show you
novia
do you wanna know via possibly a huge
novia little novia
maybe mismo
okay what does that mean me smoke middle
in the middle in the middle yeah maybe
something it's fine some just uh
carne asada
do you want a uh on a girlfriend with
karnasan on top oh yeah yeah there we go
i mean i wanted her to be cooked good
cook
a good chef and a big hug you know okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty nice hair too
nice hair okay okay yes just just just
start with me and we can go to tijuana
tacos put karnasana on the girls
meeting up these ladies baby meeting up
these ladies brandon moreno man thanks
so much for your time brother thank you
brad thank you so much for the space man
yeah this is awesome congratulations on
all your success thank you i can easily
see why people uh
are just
you know
that people love you and i hope you have
i hope your life's filled with as many
successes as you oh thank you man i mean
the job is not finished yet but thank
you so much yeah amen
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load
[Music]
now